[Musica]
ciao sono ma la oscar e io mi occupo di
performance art legata al clubbing e
alla cultura della notte non si può
iniziare a parlare di questo tema senza
cambiare i colori
quindi per questo abbiamo questo cielo
rosa che ha una mia foto anche un cielo
che un tramonto e qui in riviera
poi abbiamo un video questa è la riviera
vista dal sud verso nord ed è un pro
mondo
poi sulla notte
e poi arrivano gli spiriti del clubbing
questa immagine viene da mio lavoro che
si chiama spirit è un lavoro che ho
fatto anni fa in sardegna in cui ho
connesso e o trasfigurato la ritualità
della sardegna dei baccanali sardi e dei
loro personaggi che sono personaggi
stagionali iniziano il 17 gennaio e ogni
fine settimana fanno raving vestiti come
i loro animali sono personaggi
stagionali che però richiamano tutto il
folclore del clubbing e della race
calcio questo sono io
questi vestiti sono stati fatti da me
con le popolazioni della sardegna che
appunto sono coinvolte in queste persone
in questi carnevali della barbagia
incredibili e
[Musica]
queste sono le mie performance che
stanno ballando sulla musica techno i
passi della barbagia musica techno e
anche barba gen insieme sembra una
follia ma quello che io ho imparato
facendo spirit facendo clubbing è che il
clubbing e la red calcio non sono altro
che la manifestazione del nostro
desiderio di fare ritualità e la
ritualità sia stata tolta
noi abbiamo perso la sua ritualità
diventata una sagra è diventato qualcosa
di intrattenimento non è più la
ritualità che avevamo una volta queste
sono ancora io con i vestiti della
sardegna e mi ricordo un momento
importante in cui io ho capito che era
importante proprio parlare di clubbing e
di rave calcio nell'arte nel mondo come
ritualità come necessità umana
ero in un club famosissimo qui in
riviera una piramide di vetro e sarà un
dj set
incredibile dei chemical brothers dopo
pochissimo tempo io mi sono sentita
parte di un flusso eravamo tutti parte
dello stesso flusso grazie alla musica
la musica era riuscita a connettere le
nostre i nostri solipsismi le nostre
individualità da noi stessi e renderci
una massa omogenea che non vuol dire
qualunquismo era una massa omogenea
unità unità nella diversità
eravamo tutti diversi e ci volevamo
tutti bene
e questo è quello di cui parleremo oggi
uniti nella rivolo g la rai volo g non è
una religione è semplicemente un modo
chiuso per parlare di rating e di
clubbing e la rivolgi che unisce e
[Musica]
questa è una frase di nietzsche almeno
dicono che sia denuncia è di quelli che
erano visti ballare erano considerati
pazzi da chi non sentiva la musica
questo perché la reid calcio e clubbing
sono associati ultimamente al peggio ma
forse perché noi siamo più in grado di
sentire la musica appunto e l'energia
immateriale del clubbing l'energia della
ritualità e quella cosa che quando c'è
un ballo tondo in sardegna non vogliamo
entrare nel ballo tondo e farlo insieme
a tutta la comunità e non ci
preoccupiamo più di come siamo vestiti
non ci preoccupiamo più da dove veniamo
cosa facciamo
qual è il nostro orientamento sessuale
qual è il nostro colore della pelle
l'energia e materiale della performance
del clubbing e della ritualità e del
ballo e quello che ci guida che
significa e ci permette di evolvere il
nostro essenze come esseri umani ed è
per questo che facciamo la realtà che
non vuol dire una fuga dalla realtà
reale la fuga della realtà la fuga dall
oppressione sociale da dal matrix che ci
mettono addosso da quello che la società
desidera che noi ci sentiamo per quello
che è la società vuole che noi si sia o
come i cliché che ci vengono
buttati addosso nella quotidianità tutto
questo è possibile grazie alla ritualità
del clubbing alla rivolo g e possibile
oltrepassarlo è possibile proprio
liberarsi dall'oppressione sociale
hacker è per questo che tantissime
sottoculture fanno parte del della race
calciare sono così importanti perché
appunto permettono di vedere noi stessi
come anche degli esseri spirituali
sconnessi da un matrix che ci è stato
imposto e ora parliamo della dei bpm e
di quanto sia importante appunto il bpm
per unirci il bpm è la sigla per parlare
appunto dei battiti per minuto i battiti
per minuto è una modalità di unità di
misura del nostro corpo del nostro cuore
del nostro battito della nostra
prestazione ma anche l'unità di misura
della musica quando il nostro corpo il
nostro cervello sentono un battito
tendono subito a unirsi e quando molte
persone ascoltano la stessa musica e lo
stesso battito tendono a unificarsi
[Musica]
scusate per questa interruzione
sarebbe bello sentire appunto i bpm
tutti in piedi perché secondo me è una
forzatura chiedere alle persone sedute
di ascoltare musica che poi si allinea
col nostro battito cardiaco con le
nostre frequenze umane biologiche
questi sono i bpm come volete vedere i
bambini hanno bimbi pm i teenager hanno
del bpm gli adulti non e bpm e poi ci
sono tutti bpm della musica che noi
amiamo e questo è il motivo per cui noi
abbiamo bisogno di ascoltare musica di
essere immersi nella musica e di avere
rituali la musica è una parte
fondamentale del rituale non ci sono
rituali senza battiti
ed è per questo che la musica unisce
unisce perché tutta la nostra fisiologia
vuole allinearsi con la musica e ci
permette di uscire da quella che è la
fisiologia corporea nel nostro battito
solitario per appunto a diventare
qualcosa di più per diventare una
particella una particella in un fiume o
una particella quantistica che fa parte
di un tutt'uno e questo ci permette di
sentire tutto quello che c'è intorno a
noi e di allinearci e quindi la potenza
della musica proprio di unire le
diversità e con diversità intendo tutti
intendo l'adulto il bambino l'anziano
chiunque su questo pianeta ha bisogno di
unirsi a un bpm è fisiologico noi
veramente solo in pochissimi casi
riusciamo a non allinearsi alla musica è
proprio la musica che unisce come
direbbe un famosissimo dj di questa zona
bruce lee che è un grande ispiratore
della break dance e di tutti i movimenti
della danza di brooklyn diceva svuota la
tua mente diventa senza forma come come
acqua diventa acqua amico mio
e io aggiungo diventando acqua ci
apriamo e ci apriamo al concetto di
diversità ci apriamo ci evolviamo come
esseri umani come elementi come elementi
immersi in uno spazio come elementi
immersi un sistema solare in una
galassia e
questi sono tutti i concetti che nella
società moderna vengono ovviamente
razionali già razionalizzati disidratati
e messi da parte ma qualsiasi veramente
qualsiasi rito anche rito religioso
ancora presente qua i pochi rimasti
hanno questo concetto alla base e questo
è quello che sta succedendo
durante i moti di rivolta in libano dove
invece di fare violenza e atti di
violenza fanno revin notturni per unirsi
e cosa cosa dicono
la tecno la tecno ci unisce e ci dà la
possibilità come persone di unirci in
una richiesta di libertà importante è
invece di lottare
noi facciamo club in balliamo e quando
io parte su questa zona la riviera io
devo dire che torniamo all'inizio adesso
e vi spiego queste slide
io penso a questa piramide di vetro
importantissima che c'è sulla riviera
che è ispirata un'altra piramide di
vetro che quella del louvre di parigi e
nel louvre di parigi c'è un'opera che
tutti vogliono vedere che si chiama
gioconda o monna lisa che ritrae la
stessa luce che c'è nelle vallate di
questa riviera perché leonardo da vinci
era un pazzo e per lui questa luce era
perfetta e quando io penso alla luce di
questa riviera e al clubbing
io penso a il tramonto è la notte che
inizia e penso che nella notte che
inizia ci sono i miei genitori che
stanno facendo capo clubbing e ballano
su peppino di capri
ballano il twist i miei fratelli
lì che fanno club bing i miei nonni che
ballavano perché i club in non
appartiene solamente alla mia
generazione
il clubbing è la danza e la musica che
uniscono ci sono io che bello c'è libano
che protesta invece di una visione
negativa del clubbing potremmo
semplicemente pensare a quante persone
come me sono nate grazie a questo
rituale magico che unisce le persone che
le fa conoscere che le porta anche o
fuori fuori dall on line perché
conoscersi nella realtà è molto
importante
e con questo tramonto sulla riviera
chiudo e vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]